marie est et est jolie on s'est même
envolée des pollutions maritimes europe
avant série wissem mais parce qu'on
n'est pas on est on est pas encore mais
c'est tellement c'est mon frère donc
voilà je ne sais qu'il peut compter sur
moi quoi qu'il arrive et il ya des mecs
qui ce qu'ils disent rien qui font rien
qui voilà qui est oui
non mais pardon cyril messi avoir des
cojones et comparer l'étoile jaune elle
passa dans baisser passant pas de sang
pas une belle journée jours dans l'eau
vous êtes toujours dans la polémique là
encore mais vu les sait d'ailleurs si on
parle depuis le début de ce genre arrive
a forcément peut-être une tête de mort
sur le front un truc comme ça
oui quand même jean marie je vous aime
beaucoup que l'étoile jaune était d'un
très mode et pouvoir c'est à dire que à
l'époque c'est ce que hitler avait
trouvé pour repérer immédiatement les
juifs on a on a quand même le bout des
plages et le ministre de la santé qui
nous dit les personnes qui ne sont pas
vaccinés seront défavorisées
là c'est la dictature flash noir était
mort à la fin oui c'est sûr que là l'art
de la comparaison est la comparaison
c'est pas le premier à l'avoir fait
cette comparaison maladroite et qu'il
faut arrêter de la fe à cette info mais
la faute les données au jour de l'achat
les bus il faut suivre l'histoire jean
marie bigard depuis le big three main
jean marie bigard il a rien à gagner
voilà je vous le dis et parfois il fait
comme nous tous il dit des conneries il
nous dit à chaque fois que l'on arrive